avec l arrivée de cette nouvelle souche
de cornas virus une question se pose des
vaccins actuels peuvent-ils être
efficace le développeur du vexin russe
scouts nick v affirme aujourd'hui que
son sérum est en tout cas apte à
neutraliser le variant omicron les
précisions de notre correspondante à
moscou maylis d'estrées
alors que le variant au micro n'est
détecté dans de plus en plus de pays
l'institut gamaleya qui a mis au point
les vaccins russe foot ni lever et sa
version lite à une seule dose estime que
ces deux vaccins sont à même de
neutraliser la nouvelle souche du coc
vide la raison efficacité très élevé de
ces deux vaccins pour neutraliser les
autres mutations du virus d'après
killing me trièves directeur du fonds
d'investissements directs heureuse qui a
financé la production de scouts migrer
selon l'institut gamaleya spoutnik ville
ait neutraliseront omicron parce qu'ils
ont la plus haute efficacité contre les
autres mutations dans le cas peu
probable ou une modification serait
nécessaire nous fournirons quelques
centaines de millions de booster de
pouce n'est qu'au micro et d'ici le 20
février 2022 pour contrer une éventuelle
propagation du variant omicron en russie
où il n'y a pour l'heure pas été
détectée les autorités russes ont décidé
de fermer les frontières du pays aux
ressortissants étrangers en provenance
de plusieurs états africains et d'hong
kong
mitri peskov le porte parole du kremlin
annoncé ce lundi que d'autres mesures
pourraient être mises en place une fois
que l'on sera à quel point cette
mutation est dangereuse et contagieuse
nous voyons que cette réaction sur les
marchés est extrêmement émotionnelles
elle ne repose pas sur des données
scientifiques car elles ne sont tout
simplement pas encore disponibles bien
sûr c'est une réaction purement
émotionnel
maintenant le monde entier et l'om s
essaie de comprendre à quel point elle
est dangereuse les informations sont
analysés par l'état-major du
gouvernement il a été promptement décidé
d'interdire d'accès en russie des
passagers en provenance de certaines
directions
en ce qui concerne d'autres mesures
possibles cela dépendra des conclusions
qu'auront fait des scientifiques
concernant la contagiosité de la souche
les possibles conséquences et à quel
point les vaccins qui existent déjà
peuvent prévenir la contamination et
l'évolution grave de la maladie
depuis une semaine le nombre de
nouvelles contaminations en russie se
maintient sous la barre des 35 mille une
évolution encourageante par rapport aux
48 nouveaux cas enregistrés
quotidiennement il ya un mois le nombre
de décès par jour louis continue à
osciller autour de 1200